man it's it's just awesome I mean what
got you really into so fascinated with
the internet and because it is
fascinating yeah but like you really
break it down like you started to get
into the web and and all this stuff and
Napster and all these things throughout
the last decade right yeah and it just
fat you that was where your focus
completely went yeah I found myself
um
you know when I got out of the public
eye in 93
um I really wanted out of the public eye
I really wanted privacy
um and I thought this was kind of a
weird thing until I met Will Wheaton and
I his story is so similar to him he was
in the podcast he's amazing amazing yeah
he's so smart and such a lovely human
being but he did something similar to
like I once I started interviewing child
actors from my doc Mara Wilson similar
uh not the internet per se but like sort
of leaving the industry intentionally
sort of gathering herself finding her
own her own vision and coming back will
did go into technology in a much more uh
professional way than I did but will and
I both kind of found the internet as a
refuge from the public eye
and that's a very similar thing that I
found real simpatico with him on because
I found these internet communities in
the 80s that were even before I was
while I was still acting where I just
felt comfortable I was Anonymous I could
speak freely I was not known I was not
seen I didn't know there were internet
communities there were there was no web
yet so they were like sort of BBS
usednet groups and and they look like
text groups basically but they were
robust there were thousands of people
there you'd make friends you could share
content just like what you could end up
doing just over dial up so for me the
internet was a refuge it was a place to
go where I felt sort of safe and
Anonymous and that grew into all the
technology stuff uh the Youtube effect
doc yeah that's the next doc that's
coming out this Bermuda Tribeca and got
great reviews yeah we've done good so
far thank God the film takes viewers on
a timely and gripping Journey inside the
cloistered world of YouTube and parent
Google
how much again how much research on this
a lot just watch the trailer guys for
this the YouTube effect it looks amazing
I can't wait to see where will it be
coming out
um I'm not allowed to mention the
distributor reactions we're closing our
deal right now but it will be coming out
we will be mentioning that very soon
um and it will be coming out in early
2023 like in the right after New Year
basically what's your handle by the way
they could always follow you you should
follow him anyway yeah I'm um I'm winter
on Twitter so that's easy winter on
Twitter yeah just my name winter oh just
at winter yeah just at winter at winter
you got that yeah it wasn't taken no
they I didn't seek it out they actually
I was working on I think it was on Bill
and Ted press right and one of the
lovely people from Twitter film or
whatever like you know Winter's
available do you want it I was like sure
I'll take it